hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember so you don't have to the
freaking best time of the year is back
Christmas
god I love it if I could find a way to
kidnap Christmas tie it up in my
basement visited every nice and chop off
a little bit of its body to consume it
so I could slowly become Christmas I
wouldn't because that's gross but
nevertheless I fucking love it this year
I'm not only doing top 12 list and
editorials but I'm reviewing some of the
worst holiday specials ever all building
up to what many decreed the worst
holiday special of all time but we'll
get to that when we get to that let's
talk about one the most important part
of the holidays jolly old Saint Nick
himself Santa Claus there's been so many
Santa Clauses over the years and we all
have our interpretation of what we think
makes the best one which has the most
unique take the most enjoyable
performance which one do we look at and
say that without any doubt that Santa
Claus everyone has their personal pics
and we're gonna look at my top 12
favorite today why top 12 say convex
glass box this it's the top 12 greatest
Santa Clauses the season to be jolly
number 12 Santa Claus is coming to town
yeah so as many of you know I'm not
really a rankin/bass fan which is not to
say I don't understand why people enjoy
the specials they're just a little too
awkward and creepy for me but they'll
give this one credit that not only does
it create a decent and kind loving Santa
Claus but it mostly shows him as a young
man which is actually pretty rare you
tell those young uns they'll be plenty
of toys but only if they behave
themselves that's Mickey Rooney doing
the boys and he hits just the right
amount of gentleness and sincerity well
I look here changing from bad to goods
as easy as taking your first step he's
full of energy and wants to do all he
can for the world the only thing holding
him back is the budget of how much
movement the animators are allowed to
give it
whoa watch that hand there buddy that's
$30 per finger bending I know it's cheap
I know it's underwhelming at times but
you give the studio credit for what they
got and what they ended up with may not
look glamorous but it's still at least
as very heartfelt I don't know even as a
non rankin/bass fan I can't find myself
leaving him off the list
well maybe that's for the best how's
that song go again you creepy mailman
with slits on the side of his mouth
Santa Claus is coming
nice cars number 11 a Christmas story
okay you know I had to at least have one
traditionally bad Santa Claus in there
and this one is by far my favorite but
that's not to say there hasn't been
certainly a ton of entertainingly bad
santa clauses over the years including
Futurama home alone Bad Santa and the
Santa Clause and while those guys are
all fun this is the one I always think
of when I think of the traditional jerky
Santa Claus and what you want it's not
that he's the meanest it's just it clear
all he wants is his paycheck at the end
of the day I hate the smell of tapioca
but at the same time he puts on just
enough of a show so that he can
technically keep his job look how
quickly he switches back and forth you
think we think some work in one minute
past 9:00 you can kiss my foot admit it
there's a part of us that can really
identify with this Santa because he
doesn't want to start anything but at
the same time it's a job a job he's not
very fond of but he might as well
exploit because people think he's good
at it how many of us haven't been in a
position like that but at some point
even he can't stay in character the
whole time it shoves a slide climbing
Ralphie off with his point it might be
one of the best uses of a wide-angle
shot ever Oh
okay how many santa claus exhibits had a
slide by the way I never got to go on a
slide don't love to go on a slide kid
you're on a slide in a mall after seeing
Santa you got a good anyway despite the
fact that there's a lot of good Santa
screw-ups out there this one by far is
my absolute favorite number 10 rise of
the Guardians nothing like a Santa who
kids asked to be thrown in the mix huh
what this movie can be clunky at times
there's no doubt that the best part is
Alec Baldwin as a Russian Santa Claus
hey that is Jack Frost
I love being shoved in a sack and tossed
through a magic portal oh good
that was my idea who would even think to
have Alec Baldwin in that part but you
know what you can't even tell he's
absolutely perfect for it it's been a
long time old friend am I on the naughty
list ah um Northy least you'll hold the
record faster no matter we offer book
now we are wiping clean this light I'll
admit I was kind of torn between this
Santa and father Christmas from Narnia
as both are sword wielding fighters
which is not usually the route you see
Santa take yeah hand out those dangerous
weapons to kids you go hungry psychopath
but with this Santa it feels okay
he seems like a crazy eccentric who
would only really attack if he needed to
or at least if it was a lot of fun
he's just so energized and so a beat
about what he does
even at scene where he has to do other
people's job like the Tooth Fairy he
just seems to enjoy doing it so much
listen to how he talks look at how he
jumps up and down this guy's enjoyment
is just contagious
this is going to be he's a person who
just loves this work but when he becomes
a calling it's good to know he can also
open up a merry can de fuck your ass off
whenever you need it
how can not love this guy he's strong
he's a hard worker he's a fighter he
loves what he does and he's voiced by
the asshole from 30 rock that's a pretty
awesome Santa in my book give me number
9 Jack Skellington from The Nightmare
Before Christmas now some might call
bullshit on this as Jack is not
technically Santa Claus in fact this
move even has a Santa Claus and he
kidnaps him so he can take over his job
but truth be told I kind of think he
makes a better Santa Claus than the real
Santa Claus does in this version this
Santa Claus is always kind of grumpy and
pissed off which is understandable he is
being kidnapped and held hostage but the
same time look at how much fun Jack is
having in his place celebrating thank
you guys for doing such a good job
there you almost hit on even when Santos
released he still seems kind of cranky a
return to his job but Jack he's just
happy to be back to his old job again
in fact he's happy to have even gotten a
chance to be Santa for one night even
the dental work boys they can tell I did
there should something about his passion
for it he clearly loves what he's doing
and appreciates it to no end and I'm
sorry that Christmas was awesome I don't
care if it's out of place appraised he
has Christmas celebrating the Darkin and
st. Arctic you mad he might be welcomed
you know apart from the Christmas
celebrate the dark and insane party
humanity were already aware even though
he got the wrong idea you can't deny his
heart was in the right place and that he
put all his might into making something
he thought was so special it's an
example of being in the right attitude
in the wrong place but hey you still
can't fault him for having the right
attitude
number right the twilight zone the night
of the meek yeah I know what you're
thinking a Twilight Zone episode
really in the top 12 Santa Clauses well
this is a very different kind of Santa
Claus from a very different kind of
source The Twilight Zone
often known for dealing in the creepy
unknown gives us a really aggressive but
very heartwarming take on the origins of
a very unique kind of Santa our carnie
plays a drunk mall Santa once again is
not very good at what he does but what
makes him different from the others is
how much you can sympathize with where
he's coming from
he feels Christmas has lost its soul and
become too greedy forgetting about
showing love to your fellow neighbor
someone should reminder that Christmas
is more than whitening up and down
department store aisles and pushing
people out of the way again
going back to the dark and insane parts
of humanity that were all sadly very
aware of Christmas is another thing
finer than that richard finer drew but
all that changes when he finds a magic
bag that can give him whatever he wants
so rather than use it to make him rich
or just get himself booze he uses it to
give presents to everyone he comes
across and it's always the exact present
that they want suddenly his will to live
in his urge to give all come flooding
back after one night he becomes the
town's best Santa Claus that they've
ever had just look at how happy is to
actually be making a difference in
someone's life and not just one person
several people of course I'm drunk I'm
intoxicated with a spirit of the old
drunk with a spirit of you intoxicated
with a magic and wonder that is
Christmas Eve
I'm inebriated with joy and delight yes
officer I'm he's finally making others
happy and it just makes him the most
joyous person in the world for him it's
the greatest feeling he's ever had
and sure enough the North Pole sees his
good deeds and decides what the hell he
should be the new Santa from now on yeah
a little corny and silly but carnies
performance as well as that brilliant
writing from Rod Serling makes this
impossible not to feel all warm and
fuzzy inside it's a great example pelted
orally
and figuratively one great night can
last for the rest of your life as a
wondrous magic to Christmas and there's
a special power reserved for little
people in short there's nothing mightier
than the meek number seven Paul Giamatti
in Fred Claus a lot of people probably
want me to put Ed Asner from elf in this
category as the hard-working sand who
clearly shows the exhaustion of what
he's going through but for me that goes
to Paul Giamatti Santa not that I can
back this up as a good movie
I can't it's pretty stupid but still
Giamatti gives the performance of a kind
of Santa we don't see too often the
overworked Santa he's not a jerk or
cranky or anything like that he's just
having trouble keeping up with his
nitwit brother his dress inducing job
and constant noise from upstairs saying
if he doesn't get back on track he could
ruin Christmas forever I'm killing with
kindness no no no you don't have to do
that love kindness it's coming off you
like I like the radiation or something
some might say this is kind of a
depressing Santa to watch but I think it
works because you see how much effort
he's putting into it and reminds us not
to take advantage of those who are kind
enough to do such nice things the
efficiency expert arrives in 15 minutes
we're gonna be fine well we're kind of a
fine I know it looks you know it yes I
will mmm-hmm you feel his pain and want
to help them even as you're watching it
I would gladly shoot Vince Vaughn for
you sir just give me a bullet all right
I got a hustla cuz I gotta meet somebody
right now okay aye aye captain
I'm John deck rest assured my man when
it looks like he may have lost Christmas
forever
he doesn't just shake his head and look
disappointed he looks downright
destroyed like all the good things he's
valued in life has all amounted to
nothing it just tears him apart it's
ridiculous for anybody to expect
thanking me lately No
they can't it's too huge meaning I know
which of course makes us all the more
happy when things go right again yes he
loses his cool at ties but he clearly
shows anyone would in this situation
it's a much more human and relatable
Santa and in the end nobody can blame
him for what he does and how hard he
works doing it it's a great portrayal by
a great actor number six Santa the 20th
from Arthur Christmas this is one of
those movies I hope is catching on and
once again delivers a unique kind of
Santa play by that British guy whom you
always see in everything but never
bother to remember his name I'll fuck it
it's Jim Broadbent I'm ending that joke
this is a very forgetful Santa and I
don't mean that as in the characters
forgetful I mean as in the character is
forgetful he has a bad memory this one's
for me yeah Oh
happy Christmas Margaret oh thank you he
has trouble keeping up with technology
and so the elves end up doing most of
the work for him some might say that
this makes him lazy but really it just
makes him old and in adaptable but it's
obvious he's still trying it's just hard
for him to follow all the new technology
and all the new gadgets and such as
happens with a lot of people who get
older go the pin code just crossed into
Germany sir
Germany Germany countries these days
there's still the sense that the Santa
doesn't want to stop helping or giving
toys he just doesn't know the best way
to do it anymore
as the rioting starts to hit the wall he
can see more and more that he may need
to give it up to somebody else but he's
in such denial because he loves giving
so much that he doesn't want to leave it
I'm not just a fatty the suit I'm I yeah
yes he does have a selfish moment here
there but you realize that's because
he's been in a bubble for so long
because he's always been on top and
eventually at the end he does realize
the right direction everything should go
in even if it is hard for him to accept
it's hard to explain there's just kind
of this quiet
told kindness that you can't help up
really enjoy with him you want to see
the job done right but at the same time
you don't want to see it taken away from
someone so nice and so likeable you get
the feeling this is the guy who's been
doing it the longest and you don't want
to see him stop even though you know at
some point he has to even though he's
slow even though he's forgetful you
can't help but feel for him the same way
he obviously feels for everyone else I'm
Center children I'll be number five the
Wonder Years a very cutlip Christmas as
you can see I couldn't get any video
footage for this one but that's not
gonna stop me from still talking about
one of the greatest Santa Clauses ever
it's the gym teacher mr. cutlip yeah
remember him the tight-ass jerk-off that
all the kids hated well in this episode
it turns out he actually sneaks out in
secret to play a mole Santa and of
course Kevin played by Fred Savage is
the only one to find out the result is
cutlet being extra nice to Kevin in
exchange for not sharing his secret
which gives all the other kids really
angry at him but when Kevin accidentally
tells some of the boys about the secret
they claim they're gonna go to the mall
and make fun of him humiliating him in
front of the school and in front of the
whole mall but the best part is as soon
as they get there they don't see the
coach under the Santa beard they just
see well Santa himself I mean they know
it's him clearly but they don't care
they just saw a cool guy sharing and
giving to a bunch of kids and for no
other reason except that he really likes
to do it and the transformation of
diehard cynic to charming holiday icon
is so strong that even the high school
boys can't bring themselves to break it
apart it's a really great moment in
watching someone again literally and
figuratively become Santa Claus and the
strength of good intentions winning over
the hearts of those who are originally
looking to share misery it's well paced
well directed and of course well
performed the coaches ability to go from
such an unlikable jerk into someone who
really does care for kids and just wants
to see them enjoy the holidays is really
something to see and you're definitely
not gonna see it in these stills so see
if you can manage to find the episode
and check it out it's definitely worth
the search
number four Richard Attenborough
from Miracle on 34th Street insert mara
Wilson revenge joke here a lot of people
have mixed feelings about this remake
and I'd be lying if I said I kind of did
too it has both good elements and bad
elements that you can nitpick on
especially in comparing it to the
original but the one element that is
particularly flawless is Attenborough as
Santa again we just see what an upbeat
kind sweetheart of a man the real Santa
Claus could be I'd like the court to see
mr. Kringle make the reindeer fly young
flies Oh Christmas Eve I love the detail
of his costume I love the smile he
constantly has and I love how he's
always giggling unless he has something
to be concerned for like the well-being
of others we still get all the things we
associate with Santa his joy his
kindness to kids his love for his work
and his ability to win over others with
the sheer passion of what he does she's
deaf you don't have to talk to her she
just wanted to see you you ah there
buuuut young lady
admit it you're smiling just looking at
this guy right now aren't you when he's
happy and upbeat it never feels like a
performance he seems really genuinely
happy and upbeat and when he's concerned
he wants and feels really concerned
again it never seems like he's reading a
script and he's acting it out he looks
totally in there it's a good performance
that definitely deserves to be
recognized for me this is one hell of a
great Santa
he thinks you're Santa Claus number
three Edmund Gwenn from Miracle on 34th
Street
yeah don't actually you didn't see this
one coming nothing beats the original
and this one is proof of that
there's nothing wrong with that and Broz
giggling and bubbliness but Gwen's
version is much more reserved and
dignified which again you don't see in a
Santa that often when you think about it
but it's definitely welcomed as we
figure a man who does what he does for
so long would carry a lot of proud
weight on his shoulders no jewelry lies
that a thousands of children lining the
streets waiting to see you general been
dreaming of this moment for weeks you're
a disgrace to the tradition of Christmas
when I refuse to have you malign me
inspection but it's little doubt pervy
with how much he just gets along with
others especially children there's a
sense that he doesn't talk down to them
he speaks to them as if he takes every
single word they're saying seriously he
said what kind of an animal are you and
I said I'm not an animal I'm a girl why
didn't you tell him you were a lion or a
bear because I'm not a barrier line yeah
but the other children over the children
and they were pretending to be animals
that's what makes the game so silly why
don't think so you can tell that he
listens to everything being said by them
and never disregards any of it well the
only important thing is to make the
children happy where the may see or
somebody else elves
doesn't make any difference don't you
feel that way we I didn't know my sister
as long as I'm here they do but that
said though it's nice having two Santa's
as different as these two versions and
truly comparing them is like apples and
oranges but let's face it that's what
we're here to do and since we gotta when
I do think is a little bit better
he's got the stature he's got the pride
and he's got it for all the right
reasons to help him delight all little
children who come before so one of
America's classic Santa's for a reason
oh go ahead
hold it number two Santa Claus the movie
now of course I've made fun of this
movie before in my review of it and I
still stand by is a pretty goofy wig but
I still can't bring myself to say that
David Huddleston as Santa brings
anything less than pure Christmas joy he
has so many of the elements needed for a
good Santa the hard worker the jolly
laughed the weight of his importance as
well as well the weight his love for
children he just got so much going I
also give credit that the movie does
take the whole Santa Clause mythos very
seriously there's a lot of quiet moments
and even dramatic moments that really
make you feel like you're watching
something big and important go down on
this day on now and forever you will
bring our gifts to all the children
and his performance is right in the
center of it
I think Polar Express tried to do
something similar with its build up but
the Saint that we saw wasn't on screen
that long and I don't know I never felt
like I really got a chance to know him
this Santa we most certainly did we know
he's funny we know he's kind we know
he'll risk anything just to make the
world a little bit of a better place
it's funny because his voice is not the
traditional voice you would think of
when you think of Santa it's more a high
pitch unless ho ho ho E but he's just so
cheerful and happy whenever he speaks
with it that it's almost contagious you
just want to laugh every time he laughs
it's also great that even before
becoming Santa he makes and gives toys
to begin with in fact he nearly dies in
a storm just to give kids who have no
toy something to play with that you it's
a performance he made all his own and
we're thankful that he did because it's
truly one of a kind
and the number one greatest Santa Clause
of all time is Ernest saves Christmas I
don't care I don't care I don't care
this movie is stupid I don't care if
it's completely goofy an idiotic this
has the best Santa Claus ever played by
the late Douglas seal this guy captures
the constant thrill the constant
kindness the constant joy the constant
love the constant just Christmas you
just look at this guy and you hear his
voice and you just think Christmas
listen to him you don't get rich by
doing a once a week children's program
on local television you've got to do it
for other reasons that's why I'm here he
makes friends with complete strangers he
has an immediate connection to children
without even talking to them he's just
losing with Christmas goodness and dies
it's so lovable this actor brings to
life a man who's been doing what he's
been doing so long that he's actually
endangered it ever being done again by
anyone else
all because he loved it so much he loved
giving he loved being Santa he loved
being the voice of kindness but at the
same time you can hear the urgency in
his voice that it might all go away
forever
he feels guilty for loving his job so
much that it might have put everything
in danger it's a situation where
literally the guy was too nice and I
don't know isn't that sort of what Santa
Claus should be it just breaks your
fucking heart we see him trying to put
things right but then it all falls apart
even a guy he wants to take over the
position who clearly doesn't believe in
Santa Claus has a hard time not
believing in Santa Claus after talking
with him and you were to just listen to
his genuine sincerity you know I carried
this torch for more systems than I
should have that
as I loved it so much but now I taken to
making notes when you pod do it that way
it shouldn't be done that way it can't
be done that way did you even notice
that he actually said it can't be done
that way twice in the same sentence
that's not good writing and yet he pulls
it all so flawlessly that most people
don't notice they're just too engaged in
his performance he's also good at
showing older kids that obviously don't
believe that he's aware of the troubles
at home and that he still cares about
what happens to them that they'll always
have somebody who listens and will be on
their side my mistake I mixed you up
with someone whose parents that had some
problems last year and well they got so
wrapped up in themselves that they
forgot the key needed a little attention
to their voice is the kindness you could
find that their faces the kindest you
can find even a jail cell full of
killers within minutes he has them all
singing Christmas carols
they even stand up for him when somebody
doesn't believe he's the real thing my
good man you are not Santa Claus I tell
you ahead and no excuse me but he really
is Santa Claus that is fucking hardcore
and who can blame them
he may not be chubby he may not have the
deep voice but you take one look at this
guy and you just say Santa yes it comes
from a dumb movie yes there's tons of
things about that don't make sense but
it also has the best Santa Claus I have
ever seen and I'll believe in him all
over again every single time I see him
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
you
hey guys have a good Thanksgiving you
have a good Black Friday wasn't it awful
would you like to shop online instead of
going to those stores great to step over
people well now you can
because only at our store online and
nowhere else on the internet that's
probably alike until December 4th we are
having our Black Friday sale where a lot
of our DVDs are discounted so go check
them out and see if you find something
you like